Today, more people look online to find deals for everything.
From a shampoo and cut to an auto tune-up.
To help you get amazing deals on the best places to eat,...
...shop, play, and stay in your area,...
...we've created a smart, new way to find them,...
...Google Offers!
We're working with thousands of local businesses and even other deal sources,...
...like local experience site Gilt City, so you can find a huge collection of offers all in one place.
And you can personalize your deals so you'll only receive the offers that matter to you.
Just sign up with Google Offers...
...and we'll send the best deals right to you.
Here's how it works. Subscribe to Google Offers,...
...tell us what types of offers you like, and your locations.
We'll email you the best deals that match your interests.
Click the "buy" button, enter the appropriate information, and you're done.
Print the voucher or show it on your mobile phone to the business owner and enjoy the offer.
Click the "My Offers" tab to keep track of all your vouchers.
And be sure to let your friends, family, and colleagues know about Google Offers...
...so they can get in on great deals, too.
Join us at Google.com/offers.